à savoir que en france on est en train
d'arriver vers ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis qu'on a vu dans les
universités je n'ai vu quand
j'enseignais il ya longtemps puisque
j'étais professeur d'université et on
voit comment la politique aujourd'hui
aux états unis et surtout composée de
cette revendication identitaire et ça va
venir en france aussi faire des
statistiques ce n'est pas en soi quelque
chose de disons enfin ne doit pas rester
un tabou regarder lorsqu'on ce que ce
que l'on a eue ce travail très
intéressant la date du nord de nos
collègues les obèses et les vies sur les
contrôles au faciès
on a pu constater que les arabes sont
son contrôle est huit fois plus qu'une
personne blanche et pour les noirs c'est
six fois plus lorsqu'on voit ça on
comprend aussi cette colère contre les
violences
actuellement contre les violences
policières c'est vraiment là on est en
train de tourner autour du sujet je
crois qu'on en plus en train de se
rapprochait de dunes disons d'une bonne
arrivages à aux statistiques ethniques
cib et n'diaye a récemment fait allusion
enfin peut-être que on devrait revoir ce
problème différemment et voir comment on
peut faire des statistiques ethniques
sans qu'il y ait ces divisions des
quêtes craignent ceux qui sont contre
compte les statistiques ethniques
la cohésion de la nation ne sera que
renforcée et craindre les dit ne pas
vouloir regarder ce qui se passe et
admettre que la france est
multiculturelle même si je ne parle pas
là du multiculturalisme la france est
multiculturelle
[Musique]